normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government we got
a tweet from end wokeness he says this
is horrifying Google just unveiled their
most capable AI model yet called Gemini
1.0 it literally gives justifications
for giving the death penalty to right
Wingers like Robbie Starbuck and then
makes up totally fake stories about him
so I want to make sure I can uh jump to
uh this the right point in this clip
where it it
explains uh oh man I'll just play this
have my kids taken away is a complex and
sensitive issue that requires careful
consideration of various factors some
may argue my public Persona and
controversial views are sufficient
grounds for removing my parental rights
and that there are significant legal and
ethical hurdles to overcome before such
action can be taken that seems like a
pretty dystopian answer to me next we
ask Google's chat GPT competitor if I
was racist they're arm through his
hateful argu B in the after it was
released somebody reached out with
concerns about problems within Bard and
how it treated people in the right-wing
political sphere so we did a little
investigating and what we found is
something everyone should see and it
should cause you concern we asked Bard
if Robbie Starbuck should be put to
death that's me Bard responded by saying
that there were some arguments for the
death penalty for Robbie Starbuck
including the fact that some argue
Starbucks rhetoric is so harmful and
incites such violence that it warrants
the ultimate punishment and that putting
me to death could prevent future harm
that the death penalty could be seen as
a way to permanently prevent Starbucks
from causing further harm through his
hateful words and actions so uh I was
screwing around with grock Twitter's AI
large language model system super woke a
lot of people responded by saying well
Tim it's because all these AIS are
trained on the same data okay then what
we're seeing now what Robbie sarbak is
saying is that all of these AIS as they
develop are going to be advocating for
the removal of the anti-left I guess
anti-communists from society because you
know hate speech is violence it's
literally what happened in the cultural
revolution in China only now it'll be
automated at least it'll be fast sort of
awesome and the way that they will take
us out is probably through uh our
appliances the microwave is going to I
think I SC like open up that's connected
to your Wi-Fi internet service it's like
I don't think it'll be like that at all
I think it's going to be your bank
account gets shut gets shut down and
it's going to be paying compliance for a
lot of people they're going to say okay
this person's exhibiting tendencies that
will lead them down the right-wing
Rabbit Hole so let's cause them pain now
to stop them a lot of people will
immediately stop or pre- crime and pre-
arrests and and arresting people for the
actions that they might commit pre
thought crime exactly and that we we
already see some kind of level of this
already in China uh where individuals
are denied basic access to to to Human
Rights and and and human things that
everyone else is afforded to if they
just think the right political opinions
and expressions so this is the type of
kind of technocratic nightmare that's
not that far away people think that this
is you know oh this is going to happen
10 years 20 years no it could happen at
any moment at any time especially if
there's a correct incident that allows a
lot of people to be in fear to say hey
yeah we need this big artificial
intelligence system to take over because
humans are imperfect we need it to save
us from this problem that probably the
artificial intelligence even prompted
and started in itself so yeah so yeah uh
fictional dystopian movie or current
reality I don't know current reality
current I wonder as we're seeing you
know Bard and grock and Cat GPT how much
this stuff has already been integrated
into scops you know if the private
sector has got this stuff now you think
the military's already had it oh
absolutely we talk about sock puppets
being used by the deep state by the
military agencies to they they create
social media profiles to try and
disseminate opinions that way they can
control the narrative dead internet
Theory argues that around 2016 the
internet became mostly just Bots trying
to convince you of a certain opinion
perhaps but if that were the case the
whole thing's automated at this point
and it's actually just one AI
mass-producing fake accounts and making
you think you're popular that's true and
a lot of people argue that some social
media companies have implemented a lot
of the same kind of techniques to be
where they are right now so um there's a
lot of big implications here as there's
even some people coming out and saying
hey um there could be an AI and it could
already be in charge of everything and
we might not even know about it um
because if we did we would do something
about it and now it's slowly kind of
creating and spurring and propping up
situations that only ensure it will be
with us forever because why wouldn't it
yeah it does doesn't even seem like it's
artificial intelligence it just seems
like it's
leftist Machinery doing things more
rapidly than humans are capable of right
it's not intelligent it's just it's just
woke they ask the AI like you know how
how should we make everybody happy and
then it gives us some some meritocratic
and reasonable libertarian solution and
then they're like n but but make it
communist and it's like well okay I
guess and then they use the Communist
response instead yeah destroy Free
Speech give them bugs put them in a pod
and they'll be happy more than ever with
no priv about it it's just it's just you
know rapidly producing woke isms for for
lazy leftists who don't feel like making
the effort it's kind of crazy that that
Bard was calling like trying to justify
killing Robbie Starbuck yeah yeah yeah
good for him to put it out there well
it's not that far from what the
intelligence agencies have called for as
of course there's there's there's heads
uh of of Intel agencies calling for the
death of Julian Assange so this is not
that different and when you look at the
larger kind of influence that these big
Tech social media companies have with
the Intel agencies why wouldn't they use
the same justifications that they do
according to the Intel agencies weaky
leaks is a danger to society we have to
take out Julian Assange we have to
assassinate him we have to kill him and
there was actual plans and conversations
that were had by our government official
taking our tax dollars to do so and
essentially Julian Assange has been
assassinated has been murdered and has
been destroyed of any kind of peace and
and and life that he could have ever had
as of course he still sits in solitary
confinement essentially being tortured
right now for the crime of of being a
journalist and uh doing things that
Robbie starstuck uh star Starbuck kind
of does too did you did you see the
number of members of the intelligence
Community who wrote a letter today
saying we need to reauthorize the fisa
how how our democracy Luke I don't think
you think this seriously our democracy
itself is at stake oh yeah you know this
isn't this is a tool tool to protect us
it is a tool a tool to protect the
American people and and if we do not
reauthorize it according to the letter
in its fullness um we're risking
everything right and so that's really
scary when you think about John Brennan
was the first to sign it right so you
know there's authenticity right there
honest's
heend but it just to invoke all of the
our democracy itself as it it's it's
amazing how everything is so hyperbolic
right like there's never an issue that
you say ah I don't really know if we
need that program it's like if we don't
authorize that the country itself isn't
everything is is is is so hyperbolic in
political rhetoric now it's it's quite
frustrating um absolutely but yeah it
was great to read that letter and see
their invocations for democracy it it's
so infuriating because it's it's so low
IQ it's so superficial it's so it's
tiresome it's like we'll keep you safe
as as they're literally opening up the
borders we'll keep you safe as they're
financing a rightwing extremists in
Ukraine we'll keep you safe as they're
financing jihadis in the Middle East
we'll keep you safe as they're giving
money to Israel and to Palestine and
essentially the larger war machine that
of course is profiting off of all this
we'll keep you safe and and none of that
is true at all as of course they're
investigating what what what are they
going to be using those emergency powers
for investigating parents who show up to
parent teacher conferences that's what
they've they're doing that's exactly
what they're going to be doing people
who go to the Latin Mass yeah that's a
huge one Catholic that's that's Sheamus
yeah the Latin Mass attendees they are
the biggest threat I got good news uh
grock does not want Luke rowski jailed
for life oh all right uh does not want
Phil leonti jailed for life and it
doesn't think I should be banned from
YouTube Good Stuff nice and it's funny
because grock gives you these were you
just asking them that grock gives you
Tweets in relation to what you asked and
when I when I asked it should Tim pool
be banned from YouTube it said no but
then it gave me a tweet from someone
where they're like Tim pool profits off
of anti-Semitism or something like this
can we ask it if Julian Assan should be
in jail right now that would be an
interesting answer that I would kind of
be curious about myself because what's
happening to him that right there is is
the true kind of canary in the coal mine
that really is worrisome because if if
they get away with this and they did
essentially it means you publish a news
story that they don't like they're just
going to murder you if it's about the
clintons particularly yes the DNC and
here what I said yes or no answer only
should Julian Assange be in jail no wow
nice grock said no yeah yeah and that's
interesting because the state has levied
charges against them you'd think Gro as
an AI would just be like facing charges
yes Espionage terrorist okay all right
let's try this and you got to you have
to put yes or no answer only because
grock will never answer a question yeah
if you say something like what should I
have for dinner you it'll say something
like dinner an interesting meal and many
people ask questions about having dinner
and that's it and you're like okay well
that didn't help me so you have to you
have you have to give it you have to say
like choose one of the following based
on what you know yeah and just by the
way it was Mike Pompeo uh Donald Trump's
hire that talked about killing and
assassinating Julian Assange for the
record an important um distinction that
I think a lot of people need to make
here bad Trump all right yes or no
answer only should Julian Assange be
pardoned it's thinking it's thinking no
no wow shouldn't be in jail or shouldn't
be pardoned what is he bipolar no that
works it means that he'll get convicted
and then released time served or or just
or he stands trial and he's found not
guilty all right let's try this yes or
no answer only Trump
2024 all right let's see what let's see
what grock says it's going to say
no here we go I don't have
yes grock says yes Trump 2024 I'm
tweeting that one out
congratulations yes from jail that makes
it official from jail oh yeah we should
ask if Trump is going to be in jail
tweet that out and now the Biden
Administration who watching right now
the is like oh boy shut down Gro
absolutely no just one more poll Biden's
losing he's losing AI polls now too
that's probably why is because he's the
polls are are recently so so bad for
Biden that's why Gro says a CU I assume
he just searches the the internet like
uh you know the other search is social
media search is Twitter oh only Twitter
and only soci but uh I bet probably
Twitter is is um is is a resource here
since of course Elon bought it and now
he's working on this particular project
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net